- Nawins Party war super!
- Ja. Jetzt freue ich mich aber
auf den Urlaub.
Wir haben ein ganzes Haus für uns alleine.
- Ich will auch wegfahren.
- Wann war dein letzter Urlaub?
- Im Mai. Aber es war kein Urlaub.
Das war nur ein Ausflug.
Wir haben die Hochzeit von
meinem Onkel gefeiert.
- Cool.
- Ja! Und wir haben toll gegessen
und gesungen und getanzt.
Es gab auch einen See.
Wir sind geschwommen
und wir haben gegrillt
und haben Spaziergänge gemacht.
- Das klingt schön.
Wo habt ihr gefeiert?
- In der Nähe von Hamburg. Wir haben
bei meiner Cousine übernachtet.
Das war sehr schön. Wir hatten
super Wetter und viel Spaß.
Aber der letzte richtige Urlaub
ist sehr lange her …
- Wir sehen uns, wenn ich wiederkomme,
okay?
- Okay!